good morning Hank it's time to belatedly
talk about the first half of Catcher in
the Rye by the way grammar nerdfighters
I apologize for splitting that
infinitive so I want to apologize for
making this video late I know this isn't
an excuse but my whole life I've
basically been that kid who asks for an
extension and I guess I'm just clinging
to my childhood
just like Holden Caulfield okay let's
begin by summarizing everything that
happens in the first 15 chapters in one
long sentence okay a year after all this
happened Holden Caulfield sits down to
tell the story of winning got kicked out
of a fancy prep school got in a fight
with one of his friends took a train to
New York caught a cab to a hotel where
he asked a lot of weird questions about
ducks went to the hotel had some drinks
with some women at the bar at the hotel
then left the hotel caught another cab
asked more weird questions about ducks
then went back to the hotel met a woman
who was definitely a prostitute after
earlier in the book not meeting a woman
who is maybe a prostitute then didn't do
anything with the prostitute went to bed
woke up the next day had breakfast with
some nuns and that's the end of the
first 15 chapter or so except for the
fact that for the entire book he's like
why am i putting on and taking off this
red hunting cap poor Holden you're
putting it on because it's your
protective shield now Hank whenever
people talk about Catcher in the Rye
they always talk about adolescence as
the tension between innocence and
experience and I think that's right on
but I also think that that's more
interesting to talk about after you've
read the whole book instead maybe just
because I'm sitting in a hotel room
alone on a Saturday I want to talk about
how incredibly lonely it is to be
sitting in a hotel room alone like the
beginning of chapter 9 chapter 9 starts
out the first thing I did when I got off
at Penn Station I went into this phone
booth I felt like giving somebody a buzz
so who does he call nobody he has no one
to call I mean it's the equivalent of
opening up your cell phone scrolling
through your contacts and realizing that
there is no one on that list who wants
to talk to you even if you're rich
enough everything going for you that is
a profoundly unjust experience then when
he's on his way to the hotel he tries to
talk to the cab driver about a question
that's really important to him what
happens to the ducks in the Central Park
pond in winter and the cab driver won't
take him seriously then he calls this
girl who is possibly probably a
prostitute and even
she won't talk to him I mean Jesus when
you call a prostitute and she won't talk
to you you are in dire straits pretty
much for the whole first half of the
book all he is trying to do is talk to
someone so no wonder he needs a security
blanket no wonder he puts that red
hunting hat on after his teacher
humiliates him no wonder he only takes
it off when he's in a situation where he
knows that adults will be making fun of
him for wearing it I mean anybody who's
held on to a stuffed animal a little bit
too long because it provided them
comfort knows how that hunting cap feels
to Holden and Hank I'm not specifically
referring to you although I do believe
you still have that stuffed ferret okay
before I briefly talk about holding in
the ladies I want to talk about one more
way that Holden is trying to protect
himself from the pain of his world when
I was reading catcher this time I kept
noticing how often Holden says you when
he means I like in Chapter 11 he's
talking about holding hands with Jane
and he says you never even worried with
Jane whether your hand was sweaty or not
all you knew was you were happy of
course he doesn't mean that you were
happy you weren't holding hands with
Jane but to put himself back in that
place is so painful partly because he's
remembering the feeling of intimacy with
a person which he no longer has with
anyone and partly because he's
remembering that feeling of innocence of
playing checkers and holding hands it's
so painful to remember that that he
can't say I he has to take a step away
from it he has to say that that happened
to you it's frakkin sad man okay so last
thing Holden in the ladies somebody
correct me if I'm wrong but I think this
book is just a wee bit misogynistic like
the part where he talks about how once
you get past second base girls lose
their heads and can't control themselves
that's a little troubling and also it
sometimes feels like Holden's desire to
protect people and to keep them innocent
is in some ways a way it's kind of
inhibiting the empowerment of women I
think we should discuss that and
everything else in this video and any
other topics that you found interesting
in the first 15 chapters over at the
Ning where I have started an official
let's talk about Holden Caulfield in the
Catcher in the Rye thread